-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're gonna get to the news.
President Biden said yesterday
that he doesn't think
the country
is going into a recession
and added, "God willing."
Aright, well, "God willing" kind
of undercuts the first part.
[ Laughter ]
That's like saying, "Of course
I'm good to drive, God willing."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden criticized
former President Trump yesterday
for his inaction during
the Capitol attack and said,
"You can't be pro insurrection
and pro democracy."
Oh, that's good. Use logic
on the insurrectionists.
These are people who fly
a Confederate flag and an
American flag on the same pole.
One guy showed up to the coup
dressed like a community college
football mascot.
You really think that guy heard
what you said and thought, "Mm,
checkmate, Mr. President."
[ Laughter ]
Republican Congressman
Matt Gaetz
spoke over the weekend at the
conservative Turning Point USA's
Student Action Summit
in Florida.
Said Gaetz,
"You had me at 'student.'"
[ Laughter ]
Elon Musk reportedly
had an affair
with Google co-founder
Sergey Brin's wife
that resulted in
Brin cashing out
of his investments
in Musk's company.
Musk broke the cardinal rule --
don't ever mess with a guy who
knows how to check your Gmail.
[ Laughter ]
A couple in the UK recently had
a "Back to the Future"
movie-themed wedding,
including
a replica of the DeLorean
and the creepiest mother-son
dance you've ever seen.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new book
about Harvey Weinstein,
the disgraced movie mogul
smells like feces
and has deformed genitals.
Even weirder, the book
is an autobiography.
[ Laughter ]
After singer Adele canceled
her Las Vegas residency dates
at Caesars Palace
earlier this year,
she told her fans yesterday
that she was "heartbroken
to have to cancel them."
On the bright side,
that probably means
you'll hear
a couple of new songs.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
9% of Americans said that they
have no phone numbers memorized.
Said those people,
"The house is on fire!
Oh, crap. Let's see.
Oh, uh, 9-1...uh, 4!
No, 9-1-4?"
[ Laughter ]
Not the best joke,
but very well acted I think.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, according
to the latest numbers,
this year, over
48 million American tourists
are expected
to visit New York City...
which explains why that Times
Square Dora just bought a yacht.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!